in the previous video we left off here
we were showing some interactions of
amino acid side chains in an active site
to a bound phosphate group but our
labels don't look very good we can
barely see the measurement here because
it's obscured by this - I'm going to
show you how to resize your labels in
this video and move them into a better
orientation to create publication
quality images ok let's begin first I do
want to label these interacting residues
we have two arginines down here in a
histidine but I think it'd be useful if
they had their own label I'm using a
trackpad and so I can go ahead and
command click on my Mac or you can
right-click if you're using a mouse so
anyway to right click go to residue and
label and now we can label the residues
and we'll go ahead and select residues
here
so this says histidine 249 but it is
embedded within the backbone and it
looks pretty bad so some people and
actually it's going to be a capital if
we can get it into view here a little
bit better it's a capital H is - so some
people prefer to have capital H
lowercase is maybe a space here maybe a
- here there's all different ways that
people prefer you to show this and so
I'm going to show you how we can put on
any custom label that we want so again
let's right-click on this residue
residue label and clear it now what most
people don't know is that you can
actually right click here and then just
say edit label this is what it's going
to put as the label but we can label
this residue as anything we want so say
I like to use a capital H and a
lowercase is maybe my P I wants a dash
in there I can do all of that let's
repeat this process for the remaining
residues
now that everything is labeled these
labels are pretty small let's fix the
label size the command to do this is set
label underscore size and then comma now
we have some choices we can either do
this in font sizes that we're familiar
with so like 14 point font we do
something like that but if we set the
label size with a negative number we're
doing it in angstroms so whatever you're
comfortable with and you'll see this
makes it quite a lot bigger I think it
was just about at 14 before so let's
just try it with a positive number maybe
like 18 see if that works that's a
little bit smaller you know I kind of
like that size so that looks good to me
now now save your work we are going to
enter edit mode and edit mode can do
some crazy things if you click on the
chain you could actually move the
protein chain and I've never been able
to undo that once that happens to me so
save and prepare to have to close your
file and start this part again but I'm
using my trackpad so I'm going to change
my mouse now to a two button
editing mode and then I'm going to press
on my Mac its command and click I'm
gonna very carefully select this
histidine and move it over here pressing
command again and moving this label so
I'm just gonna very carefully move these
off and hopefully I don't click on the
residue atoms themselves because they
you can mess up your structure and I
think it's permanent I don't know if you
have any insight on this leave me a
comment ok I'm not nuts about the
orientation because I can't see my sugar
very well so I may need to move things
around again and actually right now
let's just exit go back to one button
viewing mode just so I don't have an
accident in that edit mode but I'm gonna
orient this as best I can to show these
interactions oh I like that that looks
pretty good
sugar isn't too obscure this phosphates
kind of overlapped but you know just
minimizing overlap is really great now
I'm going to go back into edit mode
command click and get these labels into
a beautiful orientation for a
publication quality image and this
little 2.7 - I'm nervous okay there we
go and we do want to show that it's that
- maybe right there not too bad
okay I am again using a trackpad so I'm
gonna scroll with two fingers on my
trackpad oh I actually I think I need to
leave edit mode someone button view and
mode again okay and now we can see if we
can apply some clip actually I think we
were just about at the clipping that we
could so that I'll apply clicking all
clipping also using the scroll wheel on
a three button Mouse will do clipping or
you can apply clipping manually right
here to different angstrom slabs so I
think this image looks pretty nice we
have our labels and good spots at good
sizes and yeah I hope that helps you to
create some really nice-looking nicely
labeled images